whether you felt the annoying static
shock from walking on a carpet received
a nasty zap from doing electrical work
or seen firsthand why grounding is
really important courtesy of live leak
you know that electricity is dangerous
the concept of electrocution is very
simple electricity passes through your
body damaging vital organs leading to
death however the actual science of
electrocution is a very complex process
with many variables that can determine
whether or not it's fatal we'll look at
these factors and see just how they work
quick announcement questions for science
has first ever merged infographic
posters for anatomy of a headshot
anatomy of decapitation and anatomy of
electrocution they're a great
conversation starter and they look great
anywhere and there's also mugs teas and
notebooks link in description the word
electrocution is originally a port man 2
of electric and execution in may of 1889
new york state found william kemler of
buffalo new york a street merchant
guilty of murdering his common-law wife
matilda ziegler by striking her 26 times
in the head with a hatchet the method of
execution was the electric chair known
as electric execution a new york times
journalist chains the name from electric
execution to electrocution and the name
stuck so what is electricity exactly
electricity is trillions in trillions of
electrons being pushed through a
material by an electric field the
electric field strips off electrons that
have a weak attraction to the nucleus of
the atom called valence electrons when
you place a strip of zinc and copper
into a potato and connect them with a
wire in an led the electric field pushes
electrons toward positively charged
copper ions generating a flow of
electrons and is electricity but don't
be fooled even in a simple potato
battery there's still trillions of
electrons being moved across the wire in
fact in one milliamp of current which is
so low it's barely felt by human senses
there's 6.24 quadrillion electrons
moving across the wire per second when
electrons move through a material such
as a copper wire they collide with
hundreds of trillions of copper atoms
ions and other electrons these
collisions cause friction and friction
as you know produces heat
in fact this is how heating coils in
your toaster work you send electrons
through the wire causing collisional
friction this in turn causes heat which
makes the coil glow red hot so now you
can make bread into toast
copper aluminum gold and silver atoms
have weakly bonded electrons on the
outermost orbital so they're easily
pulled off this allows the atoms to
therefore contribute to the flow and not
act as an impediment this makes copper
aluminum gold and silver great
conductors of electricity because again
wires made of these materials impede
very little electron flow a good
conductor in the human body is your
nervous system which is made to send
electrical signals to your muscles just
as there's conductors that allow for
easier electron flow there's also
materials that make electron flow very
difficult these materials are called
insulators common insulators are rubber
plastic and glass they cause more
friction for electrons because the atoms
that make up the materials do not
generate free electrons electricity
requires more energy to pass through
insulators due to this increased
friction this is why conductive copper
wires are coated in rubber to prevent
flow of electricity out of the wire
if you take an insulator and adjust the
properties so it's a little less
restrictive and allows some electrons to
flow through it it becomes a resistor
the purpose of a resistor is to lower
the voltage in a circuit for a component
downstream so it's not damaged by high
voltage like this resistor for my led if
i remove the resistor from the circuit
the voltage will be too high and destroy
the led
insulators can also break down in burn
length resistors if there's a high
enough voltage a good insulator in the
human body is your skin your skin acts
as a pretty good insulator it's not made
of anything conductive at all the top
layer is a mixture of oil and dead skin
cells it's pretty thick and fairly dry
the degree of how well an insulator or
resistor restricts flow is called
resistance and is measured in a unit
called the ohm for example rubber has
resistance between 10 and 100 mega ohms
this resistor is 47 kilo ohms and this
resistor is just 15 ohms in ideal
conditions where your skin is dry and
there's no open wound your skin has a
resistance of about 100 000 ohms when
electricity passes through your skin the
high amount of resistance generates heat
and just like this resistor when there's
a high enough voltage the skin burns
during electric chair executions a
sponge soaked in salt water was placed
under the cap on the prisoner's head to
lower resistance of the skin this
allowed electricity to pass through more
efficiently thereby avoiding severe
burns and executing the prisoner more
humanely if the skin were dry it would
take more energy and time to push the
electricity through the highly resistive
skin causing gruesome burns as well as a
slow and painful execution
once the electricity passes your skin
and goes into your body how lethal it is
depends on the path it takes the
duration of the shock and the intensity
of the voltage wait voltage i thought
it's the current that kills you some
people say it's the current that kills
you and those people are wrong it's both
the voltage and current that kill you
because you can't have current without
voltage it's believed that current alone
kills you because you get burned from
electrons causing friction in your
tissue and well technically current is
the number of electrons moving per
second
but again no current without voltage
it makes sense to use water as an
analogy if you pump water through a pipe
the voltage is the pressure acting on
the water and the current is the number
of water molecules flowing through the
pipe per second the higher the pressure
the more molecules are moving per second
the lower the pressure the slower and
less molecules will move and if there is
no pressure at all the water stops
hopefully it's making sense in the body
electricity takes the path that is most
conductive in this case it's your nerves
since they're made to send electrical
signals the two ways electricity kills
you is through thermal burns and nerve
disruption the degree of damage depends
on the number of electrons moving in
your body per second which as said
before is technically current we'll see
what effects different levels of current
have on the body and how much is lethal
by the way all current being discussed
here is specifically direct current or
dc i'll be covering ac a bit later
let's start with one milliamp of current
this amperage is too low to cause any
pain it's so low that it only registers
as a tingling sensation on the skin
if we increase to six milliamps the
sensation changes to an uncomfortable
and mildly painful vibrating sensation
it's been described as painful internal
tremors that travel up the hand and into
the arm in the film taken when brian
mills interrogates the albanian human
trafficker the bodily reactions and pain
the trafficker receives from the
electricity
is similar to what six milliamps of
current would do to the body it's not
enough to cause burns or outright kill
you at first but it becomes very painful
and more dangerous the longer it's sent
through your body
at about 15 milliamps is when current
begins to become potentially lethal the
electric field generated by current with
this intensity is enough to cause forced
muscle contractions in a phenomenon
known as no let go muscles will contract
without your control and stay contracted
as long as current of 15 milliamps or
higher is passing through your nervous
system this typically occurs when
someone grabs an ungrounded wire with
their hand and cannot let go it doesn't
have to do with your muscles but rather
your nerves your nerve cells have
protein channels embedded in their
membranes that open based on the
presence of a voltage hence why they're
called voltage-gated channels when your
nerves send an electrical signal voltage
from the signal causes sodium protein
channels to open once opened sodium ions
flow into the cell making the interior
positively charged this causes voltage
across the next cell causing the next
set of sodium channels to open this
continues to the nerve fiber reaches the
muscle it's attached to once the final
electrical signal reaches the nerve axon
neurotransmitters get released that
cause muscle proteins to contract
resulting in a muscle contraction sodium
ions then flow out of the cell the
inside becomes negatively charged the
channels close and another contraction
can occur
when a current of 15 milliamps or more
flows through your nervous system the
electric field causes the voltage-gated
protein channels to change shape ions
flow into the cell making it positively
charged causing the whole contraction
process to occur as long as current is
flowing through the nerves the
voltage-gated protein channels will stay
open and the nerve cell cannot reset its
charge back to negative so the muscle
stays contracted this is why you
physically cannot let go 15 milliamps
isn't enough to kill you with a single
shock or stop your heart but it's enough
to cause fatal burns if no one is around
to help free you then you will die from
second and third degree burns both
externally and internally to your
nervous system tissue and organs cooking
you from the inside out
there was a video in 2019 that made its
rounds on the internet of an airport
employee in yemen that was fatally
electrocuted the employee was moving a
fan that was not properly grounded when
he grabbed the fan his body immediately
tensed up and became distorted due to
forced muscle contractions during this
time he was being shocked he appeared to
be conscious for several seconds
struggling to get help
this indicates the current was not high
enough to instantly kill him but was
enough to induce the no let go threshold
as time went on his skin turned red from
blood vessels bursting due to tissue
destruction as a result the workers
succumbed to his injuries this video
illustrates the dangers of the no let go
threshold
the no let go threshold applies to
current from 15 milliamps and up the
only difference with higher current is
it causes more severe burns in less time
50 milliamps is when current becomes
very fatal especially if it passes
through the chest causing respiratory
paralysis or shutdown of the lungs even
if you're shocked for a second the
current is so strong it causes the
diaphragm muscles to undergo titanic
contractions tetanic contractions are
powerful muscle contractions that occur
for 90 seconds or longer due to
excessive stimuli essentially causing
the muscle fibers to stay in a locked
state
this can also happen because the basic
unit of muscle the sarcomere can become
damaged from the force contractions and
cannot relax keeping it in a contracted
state for muscle in your arms and legs
this is not a big deal sure muscle is
locked for a few seconds but it's not
life-threatening however with muscle in
your diaphragm which is needed to keep
you breathing this can be fatal 100
milliamps of current or higher will kill
you with the single shock the current is
strong enough that it disrupts sodium
and potassium ion channels in the
heart's internal signaling system this
disruption alters the firing of the
heart's electrical system causing
ventricular defibrillation normally to
pump blood your ventricles have to
contract in a coordinated cycle in
ventricular defibrillation ventricles of
the heart contract in a disorganized and
chaotic rhythm preventing them from
pumping blood due to the lack of pumping
blood ventricular defibrillation can be
fatal within minutes
any current above 100 milliamps of dc
has a very high probability of killing
you but this whole discussion has been
about dc or direct current what about ac
or alternating current after all it's
used in most industrial and residential
power
for starters ac is much more lethal at
lower currents than dc which has to do
with how the electricity is generated
direct current is generated by
separating a positive and negative
charge and then placing a connection
between the two once connected the
electrons flow from the negative
terminal to the positive terminal the
flow of electrons stays the same like a
flowing stream
to generate alternating current a magnet
is rotated inside a loop of copper wire
the magnetic field pulls loose electrons
from the copper wire and the electrons
flow back and forth based on the
magnet's rotation
the current that is generated by the
rotation of the magnet oscillates with
the intensity of the magnet's position
the current increases decreases hits
zero and then repeats
if the ac were at 60 hertz this means
the current would be turning on and off
60 times per second you can actually see
this if you slow down the illumination
of a light bulb powered by ac
recall with dc while the current is
flowing your muscles stay contracted and
when the current stops your muscles
relax for ac since the current is
turning on and off 60 times a second
your muscles are also contracting and
relaxing 60 times per second this
violent contracting and relaxing causes
serious damage to your heart and other
muscles and your body to the point that
bone can actually be fractured from the
muscle contractions this oscillating
current makes ac much more dangerous
than dc
which is why it doesn't need to be as
high to cause a fatal injury as little
as 30 milliamps of ac is lethal this is
why ac is used in electric chair
executions because it requires less
voltage and is more effective at killing
the prisoner electric chairs supply
about 2000 volts of ac through the
cranial cavity of the prisoner to ensure
a faster death due to electricity
damaging the brain and the central
nervous system once the switch is
flipped alternating current of about 9
to 10 amps flows through the brain and
enters the central nervous system
causing the prisoner to lose
consciousness immediately current
travels through nerf fibers to the
ground plate attached at the prisoner's
calf as the alternating current passes
through it burns nerve fibers and tissue
from the inside out and causes violent
contract and relaxed cycles in the
muscles which is why the body is
strapped down according to the florida
electric chair execution protocol the
electricity is turned on and off a total
of three times its first turned on for
eight seconds then turned off it's
turned on again for 22 seconds then off
again the third time it's turned on for
four seconds the cause of death is
destruction of the brain and central
nervous system from electrical burns as
well as burns and muscular damage to the
heart and that's the anatomy of
electrocution